[موسيقى]
حد من اللي قاعدين هنا راح منطقه عشوائيه
قبل كده وتعامل مع الاطفال اللي
فيها تمام انا كمان رحت منطقه عشوائيه
واتعاملت مع الاطفال فيها المنطقه اللي
انا رحتها اسمها عزبه الهجنه جنب مدينه
مصر ي واحد صاحبي اسمه حسن حصم دكتور زي
قال لي انا شغال في جمعيه اسمها جمعيه
رؤيه لتنميه العشوائيات والجامعيه شغاله
في عزبه الهجان قال لي تعالى احنا شغالين
مع اطفال بنعلم وتعال اشتغل معانا والجميع
لها مقر في نص العزبه بالظبط انا سمعت
كلمه عشوائيات واطفال وعذبه هجانه جه في
بالي على طول ان الاطفال دول
شياطين متسولين بقى بيقفوا على على
الاشارات يشحتوا من العربيات يشربوا
مخدرات قلت استحاله نعلمهم دول اكيد هيعلم
علينا مش
هنعلم حسام قال لي تعالى وقح ليا قلت له
خلاص ماشي اول يوم ليا في العزبه
رحت في نص العزبه بالظبط قدام المقر لقيت
طفل ماسك طوبه كبيره وبيجري ورا زميله
ومصمم يعوره طبعا الفكره ثبتت في دماغي
اكتر وانا كنت قبل كده ما رحتش مناطق
عشوائيه ولا اتعاملت مع اطفال هناك وغالبا
كانت الفكره واخدها من الاعلام او من
السينما اللي دايما تصور لنا ان المناطق
العشوائيه فيها متشردين او بلطجيه ولو حد
بيدور على قتال قتله بيروح لمنطقه عشوايه
يجيب واحد مننك يقتله اللي هو عايزه في
عزبه الهجانه كان في ست اسمها ام هند ام
هند كانت شغاله معانا متطوعه برضو هي اللي
كانت بتجيب لنا الاطفال اللي بنشتغل معاها
ام هند بتحب المنطقه بتاعتها وعايزه تنمي
فيها وبدات تون معان ام هند جابت لنا 80
طفل انا كنت في الاول فاكرهم 80 عفريت
قلنا الاطفال دي هنتعامل معاها ازاي
المفروض ان الجمعيه بتتعامل مع الاطفال
بتديهم دروس تقويه لدروس بتاعتهم اللي هي
بتاع المدارس والاطفال من اولى ابتدائي
لحد تالثه
اعدادي حسام فكر قال طب ما احنا بما اننا
دكاتره نعلمهم حاجه جديده في الاجازه
نديهم دروس تثقيف صحي او نعلمهم الثقافه
الصحيه بما ان دكاتره وبدانا ندور على
دروس تثقيف صحي او ثقافه صحيه على
الانترنت ولقينا برنامج فرنسي عامله معهد
اسمه معهد باستير معهد باستير ده عامل
منهج لتثقيف صحي من الاطفال من سنه اولى
ابتدائي لحد مرحله ثه اعدادي اللي هو
تقريبا 15 سنه ونقسمهم على لات مراحل احنا
ترجمنا البرنامج في الدراسه احنا كنا
ساعتها في امتياز وبدانا نجهز نفسنا اللي
احنا هننزل للاطفال في اجازه عشان ما ن
عطلهم عن الدروس بتاعتهم وكانت اجازه
الصيف سنه 2012 بدايه الشغل بتاعنا مع
الاطفال قسمنا الاطفال لات مجموعات من
اولى لثالثه ابتدائي ومن رابعه لسته
ابتدائي ومن اولى اعدادي لثالثه اعدادي
المقر بالضبط الوصف
بتاعه مكان فاضي في النص مالوش سقف وعلى
اليمين وعلى الشمال لاث فصول يمين وتث
فصول شمال احنا عملنا سقف للفصول يمين
وشمال وقسمنا الاطفال انا كان الفصل بتاعي
من سنه اولى لثالثه ابتدائي وانا كان
الفكره برض اللي انا صعب وصلهم هوصل لهم
معلومه لان انا واخد فكره ان هم اطفال
اشيه و الثالثه ابتدائي غالبا ما بيعرفوش
يقروا ويكتبوا قوي احنا اكتشفنا بعد كده
ان الاطفال كلهم من اولى لثالثه اعدادي ما
بيعرفوش يقروا ويكتبوا مع انهم في
مدارس فانا قلت ايه انا هعلم الاطفال عن
طريق الرسم رسم بدات ارسم لهم وكانت
البطله بتاعتي اسمها مي من عالم الاطفال
ان لازم تغسل ايدك قبل الاكل وبعده ما
تاكلش اي حاجه من على الارض لان فيها حاجه
اسمها جراثيم الجراثيم دي هتخلي بطننا
توجعنا توجعنا او تجيب لنا
امراض وارسم لهم ميل وهي ماشيه وهي ماشيه
في الشارع لقيت تفاحه وقعت منها وقعت
خدتها وكلتها على طول بطنها وجعتها راحت
للدكتور الدكتور اداها حقنه بما انهم
اطفال هيخافوا من الحقن فخافوا ياكلوا اي
حاجه من اللي على الارض وغسلو ويغسلوا
ايديهم قبل الاكل وبعتوا فضلنا ثلاث شهور
مع الاطفال نعلمهم دروس تثقيف صحي اللي
ترجمناها خلصنا تقريبا ثلاث ارباع المنهج
وجت نهايه الصيف انتهت فقررنا نعمل لهم
حفله و كانت الحفله الاولى الحفله
الصادمه وزي ما حاتم صاحبي بيقول الجاذبيه
الارضيه ما كانتش شغاله مع الاطفال خالص
المفروض الاطفال يقعدوا لتحت بيطلعوا لفوق
اللي بيطير واللي بيطلع على الحيطه واللي
طلع فوق السقف بتاع الفصول وجايب ازاز
يحدف
علينا وفي واحد اسمه محمد طفل اسمه محمد
ده بيته جنب المقر على طول بيته اربعه
ادوار تقريبا طلع فوق خالص وجاب زميله
ويجيبه طوب ويحد فوا علينا طبعا الحفله
انتهت اجهدت يعني انتهت قبل بدايتها اصلا
يعني ما قدرناش نسيطر على اطفال خالص
والفكره ترسخت في دماغي اللي احنا مش نقدر
نتعامل مع الاطفال دول ومش هنقدر نغيرها
خالص وطبعا قلت بقى الدنيا سودت خالص
المجهود اللي انا بذلته انا وزمايلي طول
الثلاث شهور بتوع الاجازه والصيف والحر
وعزبه الهجانه
والمواصلات كله راح على الفاضي ففقدت الام
انا شخصيا فقدت الامل لكن حسام وزميلي
التانيين ما فجرتو الامل قالوا بما اننا
احنا قدرنا نجيب برنامج ثقافه صحيه
فرنساوي وقدرنا نديه للاطفال وفي بعد
الاطفال اتعلموا ليه لا نجيب برنامج تعديل
سلوكي للاطفال وانا كنت شغال دكتور نفسيه
ساعتها يعني فب قاللي بما انك نفسيه طب ما
تجيب برنامج انت قلتله العيال دول نفسيتهم
زي الزفت ولا هينفع معاهم اي حاجه خالص
وهو دور بنفسه قلق برنامج تعديل سلوكي
باللغه الانجليزيه للاطفال مناهج برض
دراسيه من سنه اولى ابتدائي الاله اعدادي
وقالها نترجمها ونديها
للاطفال
قلت له انا مش هشتغل معاكم خالص قاللي طب
ترجم على ال قلت له ماشي المفروض ان احنا
كنا نشتغل ان هم يشتغلوا مع اطفال من شهر
واحد لشهر 3 2013 اللي هي تقريبا في اجازه
نص السنه ولحد قبل الامتحانات عشان ما ن
عطلهم البرنامج اللي هو جابه كان
بالانجليزي وبدانا نقراه ونترجم فيه
البرنامج بيعلم الطفل ازاي يتعامل مع
زميله في الفصل ازاي يتعامل مع المدرس
بتاعه ازاي يروح البيت يتعلم يتعامل مع مع
اخواته وباباه ومامته ازاي يتعامل مع
جيرانه ازاي لما
يتخانق او حد يتخانق معاه ازاي يمتص الغضب
ويتعامل معاه كان احد الدروس اللي انا
ترجمتها درس اسمه كونفليكت ريزليوشن او
بالبلدي ثقافه الاختلاف وكان فصل من اول
لثالثه ابتدائي الدرس بالظبط انت لو انت
وصاحبك بتلعبوا كوره واتخانقت مع بعض تعمل
ايه اول
حاجه تقول رايك
وصاحبك يسمعه وبعدين صاحبك يتكلم وانت
تسمعه وتسكت خالص انتوا الاتنين لو قدرتوا
توصلوا لحل من الكلام بتاعكم كان ب ما
قدرتو ما تتخانقو وتروحوا لحد اكبر منكم
هو اللي يحل بينكم اهم حاجه ما تتخانقو
طبعا انا لقيت نفسي ما بعملش كده فقلت
العيال بتوع حزبه الهجانه دول هيتعاملوا
ازاي يعني المهم انا ترجمت واديته لحسام و
بدا الشباب فعلا كان في متطوعين ومتطوعات
ومعاهم ام هند بداوا ينزلوا
الاطفال من شهر واحد لشهر 3
2013 اشتغلوا مع الاطفال وعمل حاجه اسمها
سكول رولز او كلاس رولز قواعد كده علقوها
في الفصل سبع قواعد كل طفل هيمشي عليها
طول الفتره كلها كنا بننزل لهم مره في
الاسبوع كل طفل هيمشي على السبع قواعد دول
هياخد نقط واللي يجمع اكتر نقط في الاخر
هياخد جايزه زياده عن زمايله وقالوا لهم
احنا هنعمل لكم حفله انا كل الفتره دي انا
ما كنتش موجود انا كنت بترجم بس هم اللي
كانوا بينزلوا مع الاطفال لان انا كانت
فكرتي ان الاطفال مش هيتعلموا يعني المهم
هم راحوا وعملوا القواعد دي القواعد كان
اول حاجه ما تتكلمش غير باذ اثنين ما
تتحركش غير باذن لاثه والمدرس بيتكلم
ماحدش يتكلم هم سبع حاجات كل وكل طالب
يتعمل له زي اي دي كده بيدخل بيه وتعمل له
زي ورقه كبيره يجمع فيها عدد النقط اللي
هيتكلم اللي هياخدها عشان الثلاثه الاوائل
على كل فصل هياخدوا ال جوايز في الاخر
وبداوا يشتغلوا معاهم وبعدين جت معاد
الحفله الثانيه او الحفله الاخيره اللي هي
بتاعه وكانت يوم
1/2013 وكان يوم جمعه حسام قال لي تعال
احضر الحفله قلت له
لا يا عم تعال احضر قلت له لا يا عم ايه
الحفله دي بص هنفضل نزعق للعيال وتعم
ونسلم فيهم والعيال يحدفوا علينا طوب قال
وام هند كلمتني قالت لي دكتور احمد تعالى
فرحت المقر كان نضيف تماما نضيف جدا الارض
متنظفه الزينه
متعلقه الاطفال كلهم لابسين لبس جديد
البنات مسرحين شعرهم وعاملين فيونكات
واشتغالات في شعرهم وكلهم الجاذبيه شغاله
معاهم جدا كلهم قاعدين على الارض على
الديسكات مفيش حد بيتحرك غير
باذن
اول ما دخلت خالص لقيت بنتت صغيره كده
جريت عليا مستر احمد مستر احمد انت فينك
من زمان ما بتجيش
ليه انا بصيت كده وتنحت ايه ده انت مين يا
بنتي ايه يا مستر انت كنت بترسم لنا ماتش
بتيجي
ليه معلش الغلا بقى والحاجات اللي احنا
فيها فلقيت ام هند بتقوللي يا دكتور احمد
دي بنت اسمها فرحه وبقها ست شهور بتسال
عليك انت ما بتجيش ليه طبعا انا اتصدمت
وقفت متنح كده ايه ده فاكراني لسه انا
اصلا مش فاكرها انا مش فاكر اللي انا
شفتها قبل كده طبعا يعني الفكر او الموقف
ده كان صادم جدا بالنسبه لي ده غير الفكره
تماما عن العفاريت بتوع عثبه الهجانه في
مخيلتي قلت يا يعني انا فعلا اثرت في
الجماعه دول من غير ما احس وهي لسه
فاكراني لحد دلوقتي فكره اللي انا كنت
برسم لها في الفصل فانا فضلت قاعد جنبها
طول
الحفله بعدين الاطفال فضلوا يغنوا ويعملوا
سكتشات
ومسرحيات وبعدين هم كانوا هم كانوا ين طفل
او 80 عفريت يعني طفل كانوا كلهم قاعدين
وكنا منبهين عليهم كل واحد هيدخل بالاي دي
بتا اللي احنا عملناه وما يجيبش حد من
اصحابه اللي مش في الجمعيه معاه واي حد
يجيب باباه ومامته مفيش مشكله
بس اللي حصل ان اكتر من 80 طفل جم هما مش
80 بس تقريبا كانوا 822 واحنا كنا جايبين
هدايا احنا كنا ساعتها لسه يعني لسه في
امتياز وما كناش بنبط فلوس يعني كان 200
جنيه تقريبا فاللي قدرنا نجيبه جبنا 80
قلم و 80 سلسله هدايا للاطفال كلهم وجبنا
للثلاثه الاوائل على كل
فصل هدايا مخصوصه زياده يعني احنا وزعنا
كله على كل هدايا وبعدين الثلاثه الا
نادينا سميهم وكرمنا وادينا لهم هدايا
زياده ووزعنا الهدايا وبعدين فجاه كده في
طفل فضل يعيط في جنب كده ويعيط ففي حد قال
لي يا مستر في واحد بيعيط فرحت له قلت له
ملك يا حبيبي بتعيط ليه مارضيش يرد فلاحظت
ان هو مش معاه قلم وسلسله بتوع سبنش بوب
زي الزمالك فضلنا نسال المهم وصلنا في
الاخر ان الطفل ده اصلا مش معانا في
الجامعيه وجاي داخل وطبعا لما لقى زمايله
كلهم خدوا هدايا وهو ماخدش هو كان قاعد في
الاخر عشان كده ماخدش فضل
يعيط لقينا بنت من البنات طبعا الثلاثه
الاول على كل فصل كانوا بنات طبعا يعني ان
هم اللي
بيقعدوا اه يعني هم البنات اللي قاعدين
لكن الولاد مش فاضيين يعني وراهم حاجات
تانيه ففي بنت من اللي طال من الثلاثه
الاوائل اللي
طلعوا جت قالت انا اخدت هديتين هديه عشان
انا الاولى وهديه زيي زمايلي فانا متبرعه
بالهديه بتاعتي اللي هي
القلم والسلسله لزميلي عشان هو بيعط طبعا
يعني انا يعني كنت في صدمه اصلا طول اليوم
من ساعه ما فرحه قابلتني انا كنت مصدوم
يعني وقلت اكيد الشغل بتاع حسام وحاتم
وزميلي كلهم جاب تاثير فعلا مع الاطفال
وانا اللي كنت غلطان وندمت فعلا ان انا ما
نزلتش مع الاطف
ا الاعلام الفكره الا الاعلام وصلها لنا
عن المناطق العشوائيه فكره خطئه تماما وعن
تجربه لان انا عشت التجربه
دي الاطفال اكتر ناس ممكن يتغيروا واي حد
عايز يشتغل او يغير اي مجتمع المفروض يبدا
مع الاطفال لان هم اسهل من الكبار حتى لو
ماحسش بده لان انا جيت لقيت فرحه فاكراني
وانا اصلا مش
فاكرها الاطفال عرفوا تخصص كل واحد فينا
انا انا كنت قلت لهم عايز اتخصص امراض قلب
وغنوا لكل واحد فينا اغنيه لها علاقه
بالتخصص بتاعه والاطفال فيسب الهجانه
غنولي الاغنيه
دي يا دكتور احمد يا محبوب يا طبيب
الاحبك احب مش عادي انت زهره الوادي بحبك
حب مش عادي انت زهره
الوادي
شكرا
b